We have a function f that assumes the value 1 when x = µ
that goes to 0 when x goes to ±∞.
It so happens that it looks like a bell curve.
The fact that it looks like a bell curve is not entirely obvious,
but you have to take my word for it.
This--what I would consider a relatively simple formula--
describes the limit of making infinitely many coin flips.
In fact, it describes the limit of computing a mean over any set of experiments.
This is a very powerful result.
No matter what you do when you drive n to very large numbers you get a bell curve like this.
There is one flaw here, and I'll tell you about the flaw without going into detail.
That is the area underneath this curve doesn't always add up to 1.
In fact, without proof, it adds up to √2πσ².
The reason why this matters is deeply buried in probability theory.
But it turns out we want all these areas to add up to 1 just as much as we wanted
a coin flip and its complement to add up to 1.
The true normal distribution is normalized by just the inverse of this thing over here--1/√2πσ².
So, that is the normal distribution of any value x indexed by the parameter µ and σ².
So, this is a very deep piece of mathematics.
Now, we will apply it a little bit for you to practice how the normal distribution looks in the field.